quello a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono un ragazzo
comodo sia porta del minchiate voglio
iniziare subito perché voglio fare una
roba assurda vedere che cazzo succede è
una specie di esperimento ragazzi voglio
provare a far dialogare e via con
cleverbot e vedere che cazzo succede se
dialogano entrambe io leggo che cosa si
dicono a vicenda allora la prima
partenza allora la partenza e va beh
prima di partire scrivo qualcosa io
perché sennò non parleranno mai nella
vita e vi e ti presento cleverbot saluta
saluta pesa la mia partenza poi non
scriverò più un cazzo di mio voglio
vedere che cosa tutti
niente io però sono d'accordo va bene ok
è questa la devo fare un cambio di
webcam tattico ogni volta però sono il
microfono lista webcam e un po diverse
ok ok
[Musica]
e la cosa per chi vuole fare che vuoi
fare c'è poi fare parte no cazzo
sbagliato a scrivere indoor navi dove
sei mica pure di fare avanti e indietro
per the road
non lo so quanti chili che jason magra e
zia sfodera la tua intelligenza
incredibile e fammi capire sono di
chicchi che caldwell e tamer data da
vari scrivere tu però è stronzate merda
pc è il vaffan
no no quella madonna cosa è successo ci
ha messo mezz'ora a riscriverla merdate
poi sbagliato in via ma [ __ ] o o
dio mio io no ma guardando avevo dubbi
giuro c'è una roba loro lunga vieni sono
pronta per i cerchi ok e loro nostrana
ragazzi perché mi sento come se fossi
tipo il terzo incomodo per fare cosa va
beh non lo sto faccio finta che l'abbia
scritto giusto per vedere se sei un
fantasma chiamare un dialogo tra premi
nobel proprio geniale cazzo un fantasma
che cazzo perché problemi a dalla vita
io non sono fantasmi altrimenti non
parlerei con te perché mi vuoi portare a
casa tua
minchia questa era geniale però ho detto
sei un ragazzino io voglio capire dove
vanno a parare ste due allora
chiariamoci la madonna che sta
passion solo un maschio perfetto mica
sei un jack lever aborto sta vincendo la
la vita proprio c'è e geniale che cazzo
se fuori ragazzi non ne ho idea
come ti chiami sembra che sia venuto
anch'io vivo con voi per con la
curiosità mille di vedere che cazzo
succede janis che nome di merda tra le
trou faccio anche un e tu così almeno
sembra un po più gente per jennifer non
guardano il marpione che inizia
rimorchiare in pronto a farfallone che
non sei altro parati jennifer che ti sta
facendo grazie anche il tour veramente
fa cagare prova che fai
che fai zio ciatto con te che cazzo di e
faccia shuttle emma lo sapevo anch'io
factor carta conte ragazzi di fico due
cartoni in faccia entrambi io con te non
fa ridere porca [ __ ] dando sono io il
[ __ ] che passa da una parte
all'altra non ti preoccupare scrivi pure
stronzate va bene andiamo a letto che
sono capisce che cazzo lo ha detto
nipoti dormi porci dauni pochi i pochi
porti ok per cazzola al cinema attivati
va dai cazzo dai nove case che c'è il
letto dio santo ci voleva tanto e siamo
sul 8 ragazzi ok a casa tua o mio dio ti
ringrazio chi fa i cui ti faccio i korn
ti fa mi facci i korn perfetto già fatto
ma [ __ ] bravo bravo cazzo breves
tu sei un uomo porca vacca tutti
dobbiamo prendere esempio
io ne ho 15 ai 15 cosa penn i falli
vedere le tette fagli vedere le mostre
domani te lo faccio vedere capo che
avviso porta una terza abbondante corsa
si stanno invertendo i ruoli ragazzi
come spiega le tette dei due fatemi
capire se sta uscendo fuori padri erano
acconciati vaud è che fini di una quinta
di reggiseno si però è una roba lesbo e
io ce l'ho lunghissimo ma visto che mi
molli non lo vedrai mai bravo ragazzo sa
che uomo viola dal lavoro ragazzi e
fantastico a ritmi sente quando volete
provare ad avvicinare due vostri amici
per farli conoscere
mi sembra una roba del genere cazzo
bacio in bocca mettici una cristo di
lingua pure tutti erano fuori bacio con
ali
sì sto godendo io state vedendo che si
muovono e si stringono immaginatevi ci
sono lazio sul tettuccio sul sì ravasi e
fendi cosa ce l'hai già dudù dudù dudù
dada da.mi toglie la camicia è la
madonna ti bacio gli addominali ilardo
mina lizzy attiva cioè la corsa sia
addominali coscia poi glutei poi andiamo
un po sotto c'è anche lo sterno clay
doma stride of italian alcuni sbatti
contro i tour kitoko i pettorali quali
pettorali sa le tette dio mio ti spinga
il sofri non è che uno è come budget it
o così però dai fatti un po di cose che
mi sento misto giudice il tennis è udite
così no cosa ti erano così vicini ma no
mi rivesto perché è questo che fatto
pover'uomo tisbe bravo bravo insisti
insisti fatti svestire i primi test a me
[ __ ] forte o che cosa tragica su cosa
si sveste ti leggo all'età d'oro
lo adoro cazzola bellissimo weekend e we
sing cosa spingi che sei nato che cazzo
spingi cosa spinge midi vinco cioè fra
copiare due conigli di vik l'amore
secondo i robot ragazzi ci tengono ferma
ma sei tu la donna che sono stanchi ma è
lei la donna to sync ce l'hai lungo così
ok così c'è un cazzo che così c'è il
salto dalla è stato l'api niente uguale
più brutto della storia non ho mai visto
una cosa così allora addio
e vabbè l'abbiamo provando ora si te la
dò volentieri ragazza mia 66 confusa una
forte cioè come andare a fare una corsa
campetti tocco il coso sarai aj ci sai
bene prendo un cotè forza è la trama di
shining l'ho già vista con limiti e
scappini che scappi facebook si spaventa
che allontano con il conte alla madonna
che cazzo era un araki assurda è sempre
comunque una storia d'amore migliore di
twilight crediamo tutti così che bella
che bella perla si enti abbraccio tenga
il so che dite addio sei una donna che
come
la mia vita ma avrei mai pensato di
scrivere una cosa del genere però che va
beh
godo che oggi ha tantissimo da certe
ragazzi la tartaruga a parte lui a
quella che c'è nell'acquario spero bacio
della buonanotte lancio della bomba
costi cristo di baci se dormo almeno
quello bacio dove vuoi tu
avete rotto il cazzo buona cazzo notte
ok non so se si è capita sta cosa dove
di dormire dormi notte dormiglione diamo
creek chi cazzo è che l'accordo ragazzi
è stato orribile mai più fare una cosa
del genere la mia vita a un computer
all'altro è stranissimo tipo se metto il
braccio così si vede nell'altra web ca
tipo per montarlo ci metterò la vita ma
ok e per montare cosa per montare due
[ __ ] che tentano di ingrossarsi a
vicende che se prendo due scheletri sono
più romantici katz che roba orribile c'è
ma fatemi capire tu che ragazzi è stata
è stato orribile
c'è il video ti è piaciuto i ragazzi
servito mi è piaciuto lasciate un
commento
è un piatto hai dimenticato anche alla
pagina face book che come in ogni bp è
in descrizione anche a pagina di
facebook e come ogni video tratta
descrizione hai voglia di fare anche il
resto e non siete ancora iscritti
ecco la mia bella ragazzi ti prego bello
you can see ragazze